[Musique]
la plupart des attaques ont lieu après
le coucher du soleil alors comme tous
les soirs les hommes sont sur leur garde
ils sont là
le danger est juste derrière ces arbres
chadai enlève son t-shirt de couleur
vive pour ne pas énerver les animaux
des troupeaux d'éléphants sauvages
qui peuvent charger à tout moment
ils sont en train de se rapprocher du
village
c'est la nuit les éléphants viennent
dans nos champs à la recherche de
nourriture il détruisent tout
c'est terrible à l'instant où ils
viennent dans le champ il s'aggage tout
on peut pas faire grand-chose on essaie
de les chasser d'allumer un feu mais ça
marche pas toujours
[Musique]
ces dernières années au Zimbabwe le
conflit entre humain et les fonds a pris
une tournure dramatique 10 personnes en
moyenne sont tuées chaque mois selon les
chiffres du gouvernement
le travail de tinaché Pharao responsable
des parcs nationaux du pays est devenu
très compliqué
ce jour là encore à l'arrière de son
pick-up
il transporte un cercueil
on vient de recevoir une nouvelle
tragique un homme de 30 ans a été
piétiné à mort par un éléphant c'est
dévastateur
encore un mort
et encore une famille endeuillée
au village les funérailles commencent
des champs et des danses
auxquelles se mêlent désormais la colère
les animaux ne devraient pas dominer les
hommes chaque année des gens meurent
c'était mon frère j'ai tellement mal et
eux ils continuent de protéger les
éléphants
son frère est mort dans le champ qu'il
cultivait en bordure de rivière la
police est venue enquêter sur
l'accidents l'ont poursuivi dans tout le
champ ils ont déchiré ses vêtements
lorsqu'on est arrivé on l'a vu allongé
au sol les yeux dans le vide
la population humaine s'accroît celle
des animaux aussi ils doivent partager
les mêmes ressources lorsqu'on dit qu'il
y a une compétition pour les ressources
naturelles c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
il y a trop d'éléphants ils sont trop
nombreux
trop d'éléphant c'est le revers de la
médaille le Zimbabwe fait figure de
bonne élève dans la préservation de
l'espèce il y a 100 000 pachidermes dans
le pays un quart des éléphants d'Afrique
et leur population augmente de 5% chaque
année
plusieurs spécialistes estiment en fait
qu'il y aurait deux fois trop
d'éléphants au Zimbabwe par rapport à
l'espace qui aux ressources disponibles
tarsiciusement et ranger son travail à
l'origine c'est de protéger les
éléphants aujourd'hui pourtant il baisse
les bras lui aussi oui
on doit pouvoir les réguler peut-être en
les vendant peut-être avec des permis de
chasse une autre méthode ça serait de
les transférer dans d'autres pays
aucune solution satisfaisante alors les
Rangers choisissent bien souvent la
méthode expéditive ils viennent
d'abattre cet éléphants celui qui aurait
tué le villageois
LFN on a découvert que l'éléphant avait
une patte blessée c'est sûrement pour ça
qu'il était agressif qu'il voulait
autant tuer et attaquer
tu es un éléphant est interdit au
Zimbabwe sauf si il attaque
sa viande va être distribuée au
villageois
lorsqu'une vie est menacée nous ne nous
excusons pas on détruit
l'animals ils peuvent les prendre comme
ça ils se baladeront tranquillement dans
leur ville à eux
un discours qui peut choquer et il est
aujourd'hui majoritaire au Zimbabwe
les associations de défense des animaux
ont bien du mal à se faire entendre ou à
développer des projets dans le pays une
seule a accepté de nous répondre par
visioconférence
il faut repenser notre façon de gérer
nos terres de gérer les animaux sauvages
et tout notre environnement car pour le
moment nous pleurons on dit il y a trop
d'éléphants
mais ça devrait être une bonne chose
pour nous un avantage pas un problème
cela signifie que nous sommes un pays
protège ses éléphants
le paradoxe c'est que si le nombre
d'éléphants est en hausse au Zimbabwe au
niveau du continent africain l'espèce
est toujours classée en danger
d'extinction
[Musique]